yeah welcome to this video about the
final round of the veal tournament in
Switzerland played today the tournament
is over and yeah let's mention briefly
the situation before the last round
because it was yea rather tight at the
top we had cars leading by one point
ahead of onigiri and wang hao who played
each other so the situation is basically
of cards and wins he wins the tournament
if he draws then giri and how could win
it if this game has a decisive result
and also Nakamura was playing against
below gun basically yeah for either
points not for the tournament victory
anymore um yeah Carson was playing back
row and was a long game he tried
everything to the end but it ended in a
draw I think at one point um at least I
read something that even Magnus wasn't
trouble answer point so he didn't manage
to win and therefore winning the
tournament outright and you need to
remember that this is this in my eyes
pretty weird 3-point scoring system i
will say something about it and at the
end of the video so after this draw of
carson of course this happened really
late in the day to day because he played
like 60 moves against back row but i'll
look at the game one how against tarnish
giri so this game has as a winner this
winner will also win this tournament on
this 3-point scoring system alright
let's let's see what happened 11 how
opens 93 and he played them yeah all
kinds of opening moves in the sternum
and also e4d for and this time nada 3
and we see him that Giri plays Knight f6
g6 and goes for this some Grunfeld type
of opening here White has some quite
some choices he can also capture on d5
and here
has he had lots of possibilities all
kinds of Queen moves and so on but dumb
one how opted for something else he gave
this check right away and the idea is
that like at this point yeah only has
moves to block the check that he in a
way doesn't want to make you don't want
to play a passive move like c6 you don't
want to play really knight c6 going into
some some pin and our queen d 7 is not
working at all because of capturing and
capturing d5 so this kind of stuff just
loses a pawn so it's basically Bishop d7
I mean there are there are other moves
playable 96 it's not not terrible and c6
is also not to losing or something but
this is by far the main move now I place
them Queen to be 3 and white some
rationale is that this Bishop actually
is some disadvantages for black so not
well placed there okay we see what's
what's happening a 6 here this is a
little bit of a move order finesse you
could also play a Bishop g7 of course
but you want a 6d for here White has
alternatives you can also play other
stuff g3 or something but I don't want
her to do a long opening server here
like playing b5 gaining some ground on
them on the queenside Quinn back to be
three it was attacked and now c5
immediately open up opening up the Queen
side and making sure that this pawn on
on c7 doesn't get backward at some point
or weakness so he immediately opens it
up he and sacrifices upon temporarily
why doesn't really have an alternative
to capturing so he took it and now black
just continues developing yeah and in
this position I want how just played
before and now this position
after castles Bishop e2 we should be six
attacking the Queen now transposed into
a mainland ruin thought just with them
some extra move inserted this also could
have happened in the Russian variation
of the gruene fought with queen bee
three so on it's a well-known
theoretical position which both players
should should know well night bd7
attacking the pawn and the issue is I'm
white now place we should be three if
you would try before in this position
then numb black has stuff like a five
and also this idea of 94 using the
strong g7 bishop like is some very okay
here so before it's not a good idea
therefore Bishop e3 and now just done
rook c8 again checking hand upon if
white now would play before then 94 with
just one material the bishop so
something like this and like as an
exchange up it's not directly winning
because of the strong see porn but why
doesn't want to do that so he needs to
prepare to return the pawn and he played
rugby one there are the moves you can
also play 94 for example but this is
certainly a sensible move pinning the
night so that black cannot play night c
5 therefore black clay before attacking
the knight and yeah well why should this
night go he went 95 just in the middle
of the board um you can also do the side
step but this is just them really badly
placed piece and it's some very
difficult to keep this pawn in the long
run let's say something like this and
for instance canceling like might
consider even taking him because
a for singing it's very difficult for
why to keep the spawn so it didn't even
try it played 95 but this has the
advantage that leg doesn't have much
choice if he wants to really get the
pawn back he needs to check with the the
bishop here and now take and this way
White has netted the pair of bishops at
least and it's something to play for
here white just got the King out of her
out of the the center and black played a
5 securing this pawn but this of course
has some also disadvantage it weakens
the Queen side let's check weekly if leg
would take d5 that actually white can
capture this this piece which was
secured before because of nidoqueen a
five but now queen air five that's just
just stupid because this piece is also
hanging so black gum cannot take this
and you played a five yeah we should be
five immediately using this this weekend
Square and we see them by the time here
they started nothing with 114 i'm not
mistaken both players pretty much
blitzed out this so it was kind of
obvious that they both had this in their
preparation knight to e for attacking
the Queen and Bishop c6 Quincy seven
this is at least according to to my
database which is pretty okay it's not a
monstrous database but it's it's a
novelty but it's a move that the engine
I like Houdini also things it's quite
okay but hasn't been played before what
answered rook c1 and first I wasn't
quite sure what this move is doing but
the thing kids ideas to get the rooks on
c1 and d1 and queen too
to e to this kind of setup so that the
heavy piece is really used the central
file cm so Roxie one theme seems
plausible night back to d6 this night is
not a stable pc puts it back to the six
also probably intending night at five
and now this mentioned Queenie to
getting out of the sea file you also
need to look at this night XD five ideas
so let's say what makes a nothing new
here and black captures using the C file
so this is also why white um went away
from the sea file Knight to f5 trying to
yeah get this Bishop get rid of one of
those bishop pair pieces but of course
why doesn't agree to this and move to
the bishop away and now Bishop h6 I'm
not sure that this is really doing much
with them though shouldn't be too too
awful what what makes the rook remove it
was attacked rope the age and luke t 1
so pretty a pretty logical kind of
course of the game so one how to
evaluate this position I think it's um
it's not so easy I would prefer wide
because I just like my bishops but it's
not so easy to see how wide um could
could make progress IAM the kind of the
situation the center is pretty stable
and what what should be white said da
could try to open up the Queen side with
a three maybe at some point and trying
to yeah open up the beef I'll try and
look to be selling something like some
stuff like this and black isn't isn't
doing so much here so I wouldn't like
black too much but I don't think
blakiston in huge difficulties um maybe
it's even a good idea to simply retreat
the h6 bishop
move like Bishop g7 and this way
actually also preparing maybe this idea
e6 trying to undermine the c6 Bishop
which is anchored here by the d5 pawn um
this looks like a decent idea what
happens in the game was pretty yeah
pretty amazing um here give replayed the
movie 6 which is desirable from a
positional point of view he wants to get
rid of this somewhat annoying bishop and
of the spawn of course this Bishop for
information yourself quite them yeah
quite irritating of course and um the
only drawback is that this move just
loses the game okay losing is maybe a
bit too harsh but in reality it lost the
game basically because now white gets a
clear advantage and it's super hard to
defend may be impossible what can just
capture you and I'm not quite sure what
what Giri am what kind of miscalculation
happen there the problem is after d
takes c6 um yeah black will get a very
weak porn only six because you cannot
grab any material so let's just go
through the moves if like now tries to
grab the bishop then y takes here with a
simple idea but you see it first after
takes just 95 for wins the Queen if it
goes here then you've got something like
this coming and this one's about every
piece on the board totally over so the
issue is you cannot take c6 what else
should you do in the game he um he took
gum I found some alternative let me look
briefly I did some analysis some for
this game I don't want to forget Allah
I see it just as one line which maybe
needs to needs to show me to show
checking here and after this we have
this right this is winning all rook the
8th route the eight queens yeah this
one's but like can also get to go to h
eight and this is this is rather need
actually taking on the aid rookie d 8
and now the very strong move we should
be seven maybe this is what you overlook
this is possible this is possible oh
actually this and there's also very nice
point here if black takes the bishop now
you have no chance to to save the game
by taking here because this is a very
strong intermediate check winning
immediately it's even it's even
checkmate just just solve this and takes
only a tissy this is a major so after
Bishop e7 black actually needs to take
and then there's the very nice point
takes takes and now the very strong move
g-form this see tens g5 winning a piece
and if black takes on g4 you've got
Queenie eight coming and yeah black
takes you got a new queen and after King
move you just grab this and are
completely winning there's also these
kind of things coming so completely over
yeah he 60 really was a huge blunder
quite surprisingly maybe I no matter of
nurse or some some simple miscalculation
it happens after this was a tournament
10 rounds 10 tenth round now and these
nine rounds before I guess we're really
really tiring because they want any
quick draws or easy games they were
fighting really is hard in this
tournament
and maybe this explains that get the
miscalculation you because after all
taking like gum doesn't really have
anything else than accepting this kind
of structure your consequent take here
just to show it it's rather similar
taking here and after King h8 there's
the funny move Bishop deform and it's
it's just it's just over again some
stuff like this and even a rook wanted
to try to make a rock but not so easy in
the software once i have it set up so
I'm made again like simply can never
take the c6 piece and he needed to take
on your 60 and now why term just played
the simple move Bishop a form securing
the bishop and this is just them yeah
complete ruin for black whites got two
bishops it's a terrible pawn structure
with the porn on e6 and white will get
put a bishop won't be three which will
attack this weakness immediately I think
this is really close to lost with a good
tech needed to technique and these guys
really know what they're doing when they
have large advantage I think white shirt
should win this um in the game mum it
went oh it went away very quickly maybe
black could have defended slightly
better but I guess he was already very
much disappointed by this turn of events
because well just five moves ago it was
basically some sort of theoretical
position with with not so much going on
maybe why it was very slightly better
but nothing serious and then you six
just blundered the game away and also
the chances for winning this tournament
yep let Quinn d8 trying to get rid of
the Queen's please which light of course
doesn't want to do because potentially
I'm Lex king is more much weaker than
white skin especially if you consider B
should be three coming up so black
covered the porn here and now white uses
a chance to centralize this night after
the night off from f5 which we did to g7
there's not any possibilities anymore of
not coming to d4 so you can now safely
put your own knight on d5 and yeah what
one should leg do it's just a terrible
position he played 94 little trick if
white would be greedy now like actually
ya mates himself so of course you cannot
take but two item simply could play
knight c6 and tell ya what now if black
moves the Queen now which is attacked
then the simple Bishop Knight to d7
check just picks up the rook and so
black cannot move the Queen really oh I
mean you can but it loses an exchange
anyway so he took on c6 Bishop takes
yeah this not now hang two times also by
by the oops never know but this Bishop
pretty weird arrow here so black took on
c5 and white recaptures and now what
it's just clean exchange up and we'll
win this very easily because also
black's pieces are really in disarray
and it's all week all black spawns a
week e 6 a-5 yeah and now give me
resigned i guess it was pretty
disappointed at the end it was a huge
chancer with the win 2 to win this
really a great tournament so on yeah the
final standings one how won this
tournament with the three point system
he um had some I think 18 points at the
end so um he's ahead of of Carlton give
reenter Nakamura um and um yeah awesome
the amazing thing is if you would look
at this tournament in the classical
scoring system where you get one point
for win and a half a point for a draw
then magnus carlsen would have won the
tournament a half point add up on how
because cards and 14 games and lost no
game and won how 16 games and lost three
so cards and head plus four and one how
hard plus three and also cards in won
both games against one how so um yeah so
let me get this out of the way I
personally think the 3-point scoring
system is completely ridiculous idea and
should be again rid of as soon as
possible it simply has no benefit and
leads to completely logical tournament
results for me Carson is just a clear
winner of the thing and nothing else
he's just half a point ahead and it's
completely idiotic in Chester to punish
Ross because draw is just a normal
result of the game in fact it's the most
logical result of the game you want to
see the size of games of course it's
very understandable but you rarely get
it with three point system you get the
more decisive results if you yeah mix
the tournament right get the right
players in there then there will be
longer games and there will be fine they
had just them an excellent mixture here
and be are we they had very very um few
drawers but this was also due to the
players not due to the scoring systems
just look at the players you had six
players you had Carson who may basically
never place a quick draw unless he is I
know ill or fields them that he's in
huge trouble and some of the opponent
offers a draw and then he takes it but
usually he fights to to the end the same
absolutely applies for Nakamura who also
doesn't play draws if he must okay not
not much else to do what he wants to
fight and win every game you have wrong
how was also fighter
Giri is also a young ambitious player he
doesn't play quick draws as well but
chromosome really an open um kind of
tournament player he needs to win in
those wishes and he has a very very good
fighting opening repertoire he doesn't
play any any I don't know Petroff
defenses or something he just plays
those fighting stuff and you had first
two runs you had tomorrow's which end
but mulligan is also not the kind of
player he wants to make a draw into any
moves he even kept on playing those
sharp openings like the bangko gambit um
throughout the tournament and he's also
fighter and one and one thing I just
forgot Nakamura today I won his game
against Morrigan I completely forgot
about that I'm sorry this game really
yeah wasn't so important for the for the
tournament win but needs to be mentioned
of course boo log on again played the
bangko gambit the Volga gambit but
Nakamura played the same line that cards
and played and 21 at the end and a
pretty longest end game I didn't really
analyze the game it seemed to me that my
camera had wanted show throughout but it
was just a quick glance so if if I'm
mistaken there at it wouldn't surprise
me alright so I'm I was just trying to
make a statement about three point
system I think it's really completely
silly idea i think tournaments will do
it and usually it doesn't make a big
difference but once in a while you
simply get a tournament results like
this today which simply doesn't make any
sense um slick congrats too long how of
course he played an excellent tournament
I mean he won six games which is pretty
much unbelievable on this kind of level
he also lost three of course and a
couple of these losses were pretty a
drastic I think the first against Carlin
was some pretty
pretty clear one and so winning all
those games he proved to be a true
fighter and a very capable defender also
he will sir worsen in quite some games
but manages to manage to win even some
of them so I'm yet to sum it up I'm
absolutely a great tournament with great
fighting chest that very often I could
have shown more than one game but yeah
time is limited yeah I hope you enjoyed
it this coverage of the tournament and I
think I'll do more of these kind of
video annotated games from from the day
I like from some ongoing tournaments
I'll do some of these may be for the
loop yet coming up at the end of august
in about four weeks and there's also the
russian super final coming up if there's
a nice game i will feature this but i
won't do a daily feature for the russian
championships i think it's an
interesting tournament i just feel like
it's more interesting if you have a bit
of a mixed mixed fields a national
championship i think it's in isn't so so
thrilling often okay yeah thanks for
watching and talk to you soon with new
stuff